[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hay un país en el mundo con razones
para tener pánico a la energía nuclear
ese es japón habéis oído bien los
japoneses tienen un historial nuclear
cuanto menos traumático
[Música]
pensadlo bien japón es por ahora el
único país que ha sufrido un ataque
nuclear los bombardeos de hiroshima y
nagasaki durante los años 50 los
japoneses tenían auténtico pánico a la
energía nuclear y prueba de ello son
películas tan míticas como godzilla un
lagarto radiactivo que destruye ciudades
sin embargo a medida que el país crecía
necesitaba más energía en los años 60
japón empezó a construir sus primeros
reactores nucleares y un par de décadas
después el país del sol naciente se
convirtió en la tercera potencia nuclear
del mundo sólo por detrás de eeuu y
francia habéis oído bien mientras en
españa se organizaban manifestaciones
antinucleares japón confiaba ciegamente
en el uranio y entonces cuando todos
parecían estar encantados con los
reactores y con los átomos ocurrió lo
inimaginable
el terremoto en japón provoca una
explosión en la central nuclear de
fukushima una poderosa explosión golpea
una central nuclear en el noreste de
japón que es una de las regiones más
afectadas por el devastador terremoto y
el tsunami de la noche la mañana el
pánico nuclear volvió a japón y al mundo
entero cuando ocurrió el accidente de
chernóbil en 1986 mucha gente decía
bueno hombre el problema no es la
energía nuclear per se sino el hecho de
que estén en chernóbil y que se pasarán
los protocolos de seguridad por donde yo
te diga que esperaba y será la unión
soviética sin embargo el caso de
fukushima era muy distinto japón cumple
con todos los protocolos de seguridad
pero aún así no pudieron evitar el
desastre de repente este país paralizó
casi todas sus centrales pasaron de
consumir un 30% de nuclear a menos de un
3% y todo apuntaba a que japón se
sumaría al carro de las anti nucleares o
tal vez
entre un 20 y un 22 por ciento de peso
de la energía nuclear el elemento clave
de la nueva política energética exacto
la energía nuclear vuelve a japón y no
solo a japón en realidad podríamos decir
que todo asia vive ahora mismo una
auténtica revolución atómica desde
países ricos como japón hasta países
pobres como bangladesh y eso es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
los reactores nucleares son de todo
menos baratos en este otro vídeo os
contábamos lo que está ocurriendo en
china pero hoy vamos a hablar de lo que
está ocurriendo en los demás países
asiáticos y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando porque que tiene la energía
nuclear y sobre todo cómo es posible que
un país pobre pueda acceder a una
tecnología tan cara como la nuclear hoy
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
vuelve el gigante nuclear fukushima
supuso para japón el apagón nuclear
inmediato los japoneses optaron por ser
cautos y desconectaron todos sus
reactores así que ahora os estaréis
preguntando cómo se las apañaron sin
energía nuclear de un día para otro pues
atentos lo que hicieron fue un auténtico
harakiri ecologista si pensabais que la
energía nuclear no es ecológica atentos
porque muchas de las alternativas son
aún peores
a falta de uranio japón recurrió a la
importación de combustibles fósiles y
eso tuvo dos consecuencias
por un lado aumentó un 20% el precio de
la electricidad pero también aumentaron
considerablemente las emisiones de co2
vamos que si godzilla aparece ahora
mismo en fukushima más le vale ponerse
una mascarilla y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando porque no utilizan energías
renovables pues lo cierto es que insta a
las renovables requiere mucho muchísimo
tiempo y en un país como japón donde
están obsesionados con la competitividad
llevan años de retraso con las
renovables
ahora es cuando han empezado un nuevo
plan energético y el objetivo es llegar
a un 22 por ciento de consumo de
renovables atentos para el año 2030 para
que os hagáis una idea en europa se
llegará a este objetivo en el 2020 y
porque pues básicamente porque en europa
se empezó a invertir en renovables mucho
antes lo cierto es que la energía
renovable es mucho más compleja de lo
que parece y hace falta mucho más que
buena voluntad veréis en los últimos 8
años
japón ha multiplicado por 10 su potencia
solar pero por ejemplo los datos de la
eólica todavía son muy pobres
a día de hoy aporta sólo un 0,5 por
ciento de la electricidad
uno de los problemas que tienen es la
burocracia si queréis poner en marcha un
parque eólico en japón necesitáis más de
cinco años de papeles y permisos eso es
más del triple de lo habitual en otros
países es decir que no sólo hablamos de
un problema técnico sino también legal y
reducir la burocracia es complicado en
todos los países por otra parte la
energía solar o la eólica dependen del
tiempo que hace si se levanta un día con
poco sol o poco viento pues pues apenas
hay energía y por el momento no hay
muchos sistemas para almacenar energía
eléctrica de forma viable en otras
palabras que japón tiene dos opciones o
importar combustibles fósiles lo que es
caro y contamina una barbaridad o volver
a la nuclear
japón reinicia cinco reactores nucleares
en 2018 ya han activado cinco reactores
en 2018 que se suman a los cuatro que
habían vuelto a funcionar previamente
pero no sólo creáis que han reactivado
lo que ya tenían instalado además
quieren construir más
[Música]
comienza el proceso para operar un nuevo
reactor en la central nuclear de shimane
veréis cuando hablamos de energía
nuclear hay una cosa muy importante que
tenemos que entender los reactores
producen energía de forma continuada es
decir desde el momento en el que ponemos
a funcionar un reactor todos los días
nos da la misma cantidad de energía ni
más ni menos y por eso decimos que las
centrales nucleares son centrales de
carga de base
las centrales de carga de base no tienen
flexibilidad para arrancar o cesar su
producción de energía según las
necesidades
[Música]
a pagar una central nuclear es muy caro
y sólo se puede hacer en casos de riesgo
de accidente por eso la central nuclear
es la base de un sistema eléctrico sobre
eso podemos sumar otras fuentes
alternativas como las renovables las
centrales de carbón etcétera etcétera
cuya producción se puede ajustar
dependiendo de la demanda sin embargo si
decíamos que las renovables dependen del
tiempo que hace las centrales de gas o
de carbón dependen de los precios de
mercado que cambian cada día en el caso
de la nuclear es distinto porque nos da
electricidad a un coste mucho más
previsible y por eso es una fuente de
energía tan interesante algo similar
pasa en corea del sur
[Música]
mientras sus vecinos del norte
construían bombas
seúl se dedicó a desarrollar una
industria nuclear muy parecida a la
japonesa tienen ya cuatro centrales
nucleares con seis reactores cada una y
os preguntaréis quién construye las
centrales nucleares pues lo cierto es
que la tecnología nuclear es
complicadísima y hay muy pocas empresas
en este sector os acordáis de esos
reactores que instaló japón en los 60
pues estaban construidos por empresas
británicas y estadounidenses durante
años
general electric y westinghouse
dominaban el mercado
[Música]
pero enseguida llegaron las toshiba
hitachi y mitsubishi con sus propios
diseños y en corea del sur pasó algo muy
parecido empezaron comprando a eeuu
francia y canadá pero con el tiempo
empresas surcoreanas como hyundai 2 and
opep que terminaron fabricando sus
propios reactores hoy en día
corea del sur es toda una potencia
nuclear que vende en todo el mundo
emiratos árabes unidos y corea del sur
celebran la finalización del primer
reactor nuclear de baraka y ahora os
preguntaréis vale pero y cuánto cuesta
construir un reactor nuclear pues por
ejemplo todos los reactores que van a
instalar en la península árabiga cuesta
alrededor de 20 mil millones de dólares
por compararlo una planta de
combustibles fósiles que genere la misma
cantidad de energía puede costar hasta
20 veces menos por supuesto una vez
construidos producir un kilovatio de
nuclear es muy pero que muy barato pero
a ver quién es el guapo al que le sobran
20 mil millones de dólares para montar
una central nuclear entonces cómo es
posible que los países relativamente
pobres como la india o bangladesh puedan
construir sus propias centrales
nucleares pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
de godzilla hago cola si en japón tienen
a godzilla en la india tienen hago cola
[Aplausos]
si no lo sabíais tras el éxito de
godzilla en los años 50
bollywood sacó su propia versión y esa
fue nada más y nada menos que el gigante
gogo la
[Música]
pero no sólo hablamos de películas
también hablamos de energía si japón
tiene centrales nucleares la india
también quiere tenerlas el problema es
que las empresas estadounidenses no
pueden vender reactores a la india por
qué pues porque desde los años 70 la
india tiene bombas atómicas tal cual
como lo es el país de gandhi y la
no-violencia es una de las potencias que
tiene armamento nuclear y vista su
enemistad manifiesta con pakistán no
sería descabellado pensar que algún día
quieran utilizarlas en otras palabras
que a estados unidos no le interesa
ayudar a que la india se nuclear y aún
más
[Música]
pero hay algo aún más interesante veréis
a diferencia de japón o corea del sur la
india si tiene sus propias minas de
uranio y como eeuu les dio la espalda se
fueron a rusia y francia muchos de esos
reactores indios están construidos por
empresas rusas como rosátom pero no sólo
eso los reactores de la india tienen
algo muy particular son mucho más
baratos que en ningún otro lugar y
porque os preguntaréis pues porque son
las únicas que utilizan uranio natural
veréis casi todos los reactores
nucleares del mundo utilizan el llamado
uranio enriquecido
[Música]
este tipo de uranio se puede usar para
producir energía pero no para hacer
bombas por eso todos los países pueden
comprar uranio enriquecido sin problemas
ahora bien si tú quieres comprar uranio
natural en el mercado internacional te
van a decir
qué haces tú con eso con ese horario
natural no te resto aquí fabricar bombas
atómicas
mira mira mira dejar dejas una
estantería desgraciado que era un
desgraciado y para casa vamos no no que
lo dejase la estantería a la de esa casa
sin embargo como la india tiene su
propio uranio puede hacer básicamente lo
que quiera con él y eso significa que
sus reactores utilizan uranio natural y
por tanto son más baratos y eso explica
noticias como ésta
la india planea multiplicar por 10 su
producción de uranio actualmente la
india está construyendo 7 reactores
nucleares pero en sus planes figura
desarrollar otros 20 más como os decía
antes una de las empresas que más
reactores está construyendo en la india
es la rusa rosátom y bueno pues ya que
estaban por hayan debido decir
aprovechando que el pisuerga pasa por
valladolid vamos a hacer más negocios
por aquí así que se han ido a los países
vecinos
rosátom comienza a trabajar en la
segunda unidad del proyecto nuclear de
bangladesh con esto bangladesh va a
poder cubrir el 20 por ciento de su
demanda eléctrica con energía nuclear y
algo parecido está pasando en pakistán
en este caso los paquistaníes van a ser
los primeros en comprar reactores made
in chain
en otras palabras que la nuclear ya no
es cosa de ricos y en asia están como
locos por tener reactores así que ahora
la pregunta es qué pasará finalmente con
las centrales nucleares de japón que
permanecen en suspenso queréis que las
llegaran a abrir en algún momento creéis
que los planes de la india pakistán o
bangladesh pueden propiciar un despertar
nuclear en las economías en desarrollo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
es suscribiros a visual polític para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]